Prof: We're going to
talk today about managing
technological dangers.
And this case history on
nuclear weapons is really a good
one,
because it provides insight
into a whole array of
technological hazards and
dangers that we'll pick up in
different cases as we move
through the term.
This one is quite distinctive,
and it'll give us a chance to
explore a number of questions in
this lecture,
particularly about different
strategies,
like how you might decide to
manage dangers in different
ways.
One typical approach that was
used in this history was the
reliance on expertise.
So technical experts had the
responsibility not just to
design the new weapons,
to think about the other kind
of public interest applications,
especially nuclear energy in
the 1950s,
but also to worry about what
would happen to the bombs and
material once it was exploded.
So the idea that you would
concentrate expertise in an
organization such as the Atomic
Energy Commission at the same
time that you would give them
complete authority over the
technology so that the statute
that was passed in 1946 that
created the AEC was really
remarkable in that it
concentrated authority,
it concentrated knowledge,
it gave the AEC the
intellectual property rights so
that no corporation was allowed
to understand or work on the
technology unless they had
received specific security
clearances.
So this overlap of unlimited
resources, unlimited expertise,
and complete authority is
really remarkable.
I can't imagine a concentration
of more power in one
organization.
Another critical approach to
managing technological hazards
is the control of
experimentation.
So how would you try it out?
And there are many products in
the marketplace,
many chemicals,
many other kinds of
technologies for burning fuels,
coal, gasoline,
that are released in the
markets without adequate
testing.
So here's one that was released
at grand scale and the public
really had no understanding of
what the government was doing
because of the classified nature
of the projects.
So they amassed expertise in
the form of academic experts to
try to figure out not only what
the destructive power of the
different weapons would be but
also what happened to them.
Public education is another
approach,
and we'll see in a film clip in
a few moments,
if our audio and video work
correctly,
we'll see the Atomic Energy
Commission's public service
announcements,
designed to maintain and build
public support.
So obviously,
the public was well aware that
these nuclear explosions were
going on.
I mean, walking to the top of
casinos and hotels in Las Vegas
at night to watch them explode.
I mean, the public was well
aware of this,
but they understood well the
destructive power but they
didn't really know what to make
of what the danger might be,
the danger to the environment,
the danger to human health of
the remnants of the explosions.
Another approach would be to
limit the potency of a
technology, so to try it on a
really small scale.
And what's curious about this
was that the arms race that grew
between the Soviets and the U.S.
caused the development,
the rapid development,
of bigger and bigger weapons,
greater and greater explosive
power.
So that rather than trying to
move from a system which we'll
see in a couple weeks with
pesticides,
or pharmaceuticals is another
good example,
where the attempt on the part
of corporations is to evermore
design technologies or drugs or
biocides that pose less and less
risk but are still effective in
getting the job done.
Minimize environmental release
and exposure.
The increased potency moving
from the first atom bombs to the
hydrogen bombs in the mid-1950s
was the opposite direction so
that more and more materials
were being released to the
atmosphere as testing expanded.
Another notion that grew in
this history was the idea of
susceptibility,
special vulnerability,
that different people would be
exposed to these chemicals in
different ways because of their
behavior or because of their
specific physiology.
So that chemicals move
differently in children or in
fetuses than they do in you or
in me.
So that basic patterns of
growth and development
determined this.
And also compensating those
that are harmed.
So that with vaccines,
H1N1 vaccine is a good example
of that.
Vaccines always affect some
people adversely.
And if people are seriously
damaged,
if their health loss is
substantial,
we have laws that are in place
to offer compensation if the
adverse effect can be tied
tightly to the exposure.
So that we'll look in a few
moments,
or closer to the end of the
lecture,
at different compensation
strategies,
recognizing that there would be
people that would be intensely
exposed,
particularly those that were
involved in producing the
technology or in other
occupations that led them to
experience greater risk.
So the Atomic Energy Act of
1946 really created this
authority.
It's a remarkable piece of
legislation, and there are very
few other pieces of law that I
can point to that would give
such power to an organization.
So it created a five-member
Atomic Energy Commission that
was assigned the responsibility
to manage the technology.
And this gradually evolved into
the Department of Energy,
which we have today.
So I'm going to try to show a
couple film clips here,
hopefully this will pick up,
on the effects of radiation and
fallout.
Video Narrator 1:
: Gamma radiation may do its
damage in either of two major
ways, or both.
One, it may physically and
directly destroy tissue or
eventually cause the development
of some kind of cancer.
Those which concern us
principally have life period
ranging from several years to
thousands of years.
They can do no harm unless they
are taken into our bodies with
food or drinking water or in the
air we breathe.
Video Narrator 3:
Let us consider the results
of a powerful thermonuclear
explosion at the Pacific Proving
Grounds in the Marshall Islands,
eleven degrees north of the
equator.
The huge cloud soars up,
punches through the tropopause,
and finally spreads and
stabilizes as high as 70 or
80,000 feet,
entirely within the
stratosphere layer.
Video Narrator 2:
What was remarkable about his
comments was he demonstrated by
the late 1950s that the AEC had
really strong knowledge of not
just what the effects of the
bombs might be but also what the
health implications might be.
So they'd worked out the
science.
They'd worked out the science
actually in a more sophisticated
way than we have for the
majority of chemicals that we've
classified as toxic or hazardous
under the Clean Air Act,
the Safe Drinking Water Act,
the Toxic Substance Control Act
today.
So it's really pretty
remarkable that this
concentration of expertise and
authority and resources produced
a quality of knowledge that is
really pretty unusual in
twentieth century environmental
history.
Now, the experts wondered where
they should experiment.
Should they experiment in the
United States?
Should they experiment in other
parts of the world?
And they decided that they
would concentrate most of their
hydrogen bomb explosions in the
Pacific, in the Marshall
Islands.
And one of the atolls in the
Pacific is Bikini Island,
which is a very small area.
And I'm going to spend a few
moments talking about this.
These atolls basically are
volcanic, so that the rim of the
volcano is sitting on the
surface of the ocean.
And what you see here is really
a rim of coral and sand.
And several hundred Bikinians
were asked by the federal
government back in 1945 if they
would move from the island,
if they would give up their
homeland in order to provide a
location or a territory for the
explosions,
recognizing that the Marshall
Islands are thousands of square
miles of open ocean with a very,
very small population.
There are very few places on
earth where you could find such
an area where the population
density was so low.
Again, they were worried about
not really understanding what
would happen to the materials
and what the exposures might be.
So the idea was to move the
islanders away from the center
of the explosions to safer
islands.
So eventually,
the Bikinians decided that they
would move from the homeland to
surrounding islands.
And the government first placed
them on an island known as
Rongerik.
Rongerik was not as fertile.
You can't see this very
carefully, but if you go on
Google Earth,
you'll see the amount of the
land that is covered by
vegetation is extremely small.
So that they tried to grow
crops here and they found that
the soils were very infertile.
Basically, they were just sand
and beneath the sand was
volcanic material.
So very nutrient-poor soils
that really would not support
them.
And they planted coconut trees,
but the coconut trees were
killed by fires.
They were then moved to
Kwajalein within about six
months.
And Kwajalein is another atoll,
it's basically a ring of coral
reefs,
but it's also a military base
and they were forced into a tent
encampment for a period of about
three or four months and they
protested that they had no place
to grow their own food,
that they had no fishing boats
and they couldn't maintain the
lifestyle that they had had
before.
Gradually, they were moved.
Within actually about twelve
months, they were moved to the
island of Kili.
Kili -- I could not find any
photograph of Kili -- but Kili
is an island that is not an
atoll.
Instead, it has no lagoon and
it faces the open ocean on all
sides,
which meant that they had no
lagoon to fish in,
so that they had very poor
land, again,
land that would not support the
development of crops.
And gradually,
over a period of several years,
the population began to starve.
The military eventually brought
them fishing boats that were
large enough so that they could
continue their fishing
activities.
But they lived a miserable life
through the 1950s and early
1960s.
What was going on on Bikini in
their absence was a series of
experiments.
And one was quite curious,
it was one of the first
attempts to blow up weapons both
above ground and below the
ocean.
And they decided to test the
resilience of the naval fleet to
different intensities of
different sizes of the weapons.
So they amassed this group of
ships that you can see in the
upper right.
And within the center of it,
they detonated a bomb,
wondering what would happen to
the Navy if the Soviets dropped
a bomb,
say, at Pearl Harbor,
or if they found a fleet of
U.S.
ships at sea.
>
Hello.
Prof: Remarkably,
the Atomic Energy Commission
also hired film crews and
outfitted them in lead suits so
that they would fly in the
vicinity that those were films
were taken by crews that were
sitting inside aircraft that
were flying around the mushroom
cloud.
But they also flew directly
into the mushroom cloud.
And before they had offered
them the possibility of the lead
suits to offer protection from
the radiation,
the pilots and the crews came
back and they experienced such a
high level of radiation that the
experts became quite worried
about their long-term health.
And so that gradually the
shielding grew as they flew in
and around.
So a single aircraft,
for example,
would be outfitted with up to
seventy different cameras so
they could figure out what the
pattern of radiation emission
was and what the effect would be
as the cloud would dissipate in
the direction of the prevailing
winds.
Now, among the twenty-three
different bombs that were
dropped on this island,
Bravo, in 1954,
was perhaps one of the most
remarkable.
The first hydrogen bomb that
had been developed in the world
that had an explosive force
nearly 1,000 times the force of
the bomb that was dropped on
Hiroshima.
So that they really did not
understand what the effect might
be, what the distance of damage
would be away from ground zero.
So this was called the Big One.
And by the way,
these clips are coming from a
film that I'll put on reserve if
you'd like to see the entire
film,
called The Atomic Bomb
Movie.
Video Narrator:
: Significantly exceeding its
expected yield by two and a half
times,
Castle Bravo,
with an explosive power of
fifteen megatons,
stripped islands clean of
vegetation and took the
scientists by surprise.
The huge explosion released
large quantities of radioactive
debris into the atmosphere.
Prof: So it surprised
the President,
it surprised the experts,
it created destruction over an
area that was completely
unexpected.
When they finally interpreted
the radiation readings from
ships and different monitoring
facilities that they'd
established, they produced this
map.
This is a contour map in a way,
and a contour map with the
different ellipses would
represent different elevations.
So think about this as
representing different
intensities of radiation that
one would experience had they
been in proximity to the site of
the explosion.
First of all,
the explosion itself created a
crater in the atoll that was a
mile and a half wide in one
direction and a mile wide in
another direction.
But this graph or chart was
more disturbing,
especially to those that had
security clearances and were
responsible for funding in the
Senate and the House,
because it demonstrated that
the lethal zone is represented
by the area that's
cross-hatched.
This area spans a distance of
about 170 miles in length by
about seventy miles in width.
So if this were a perfect
circle and it landed on say,
downtown in the mall in
Washington,
D.C., it would have wiped out
all of the buildings within a
twelve-mile radius.
Within a matter of several
years, the Russians developed a
bomb that they first found was
too big in order to lift off the
ground.
And eventually,
they worried that the aircraft
that would release it wouldn't
be able to get far enough away
so that it wouldn't be
destroyed.
And gradually,
they overcame those technical
difficulties and Tsar Bomba was
the largest bomb ever exploded
up in northern Russia in the
twentieth century.
And it had a destructive force
that was lethal over a distance
of some 500 miles,
1,500 square miles would be
completely devastated.
So the Bikini explosion would
have taken an area from New
Jersey to the other side of
Boston and leveled it,
and an area that roughly would
have gone from just south of
Albany down to Long Island
Sound.
It would have destroyed all the
structures, it would have made
the area uninhabitable.
It would have irradiated the
soil so that no crops could
grow.
Any other vegetation that might
grow would have absorbed the
radionuclides.
So the trees could not be used
for building material,
they couldn't be used for
firewood,
because it would simply release
the radioactivity back into the
atmosphere or into the
environment.
This understanding of the
enormous destructive force of a
single weapon really transformed
the impression of the experts
about the implications of what
they were doing.
And they were extremely worried
that the public would understand
the scale of the damage that the
single weapon could face.
By the way, how many nuclear
weapons were in existence by the
late 1980s and early 1990s?
Roughly 70,000,
that ranged from the bombs of
this scale to those that would
be deliverable via a suitcase or
from an artillery shell.
So an enormous diversity of
weapons, an enormous destructive
capacity that was being amassed.
It was simply being built up in
the stockpiles around the world.
So what was the result of this
understanding?
More classification of
information.
More secrecy,
more worry about how to tell a
story to develop a narrative
advantage,
to be able to persuade the
public that continued testing
was important and that in order
to prevent the Soviets from
believing that they could
survive a first strike,
that we would build more
weapons and bigger weapons.
Now, what about the island
itself?
What about the environmental
implications of twenty-three
different tests on a South
Pacific or a Pacific atoll such
as this?
Well, you saw what happened to
the coconut trees.
All of the fronds were blown
off it, all the coconuts were
blown off it,
all the bark,
the exterior bark was burned
off of it.
Well, the government decided
that well, we'll just go back
and we'll cut all those trees
and we'll plant new ones.
So they planted 50,000 new
coconut trees on the island.
They then said,
"Well, we know that the
soils are still highly
radioactive.
Well, we'll go in and we'll
scrape all those soils off and
we'll bring in soil from other
islands so that they will have
the potential once again to grow
new crops."
So they were thinking about
well, in the film clip you saw a
few minutes ago,
you saw the Atomic Energy
Commission official saying that
they understood what the key
routes of exposure might be,
and those were via air,
via food, and via drinking
water,
or by dermal uptake,
through the skin.
Now, those are the four routes
of exposure that we would think
about today if we were wondering
about the risk or the hazards of
any technology.
What's the route of exposure?
Is it by air,
is it by food,
is it by inhalation,
is it by dermal uptake?
These are all ways that
chemicals can get in your body.
So understanding their
persistence in vegetation,
their pattern of accumulation
in different kinds of foods,
did the compounds make their
way into drinking water?
And what would be their
persistence?
What would be their ecological
pathways?
How would they move through the
environment?
And what would the long-term
threat be?
So here's an example.
After planting 50,000 coconut
trees, they found no hint that
there would be a problem with
the coconuts,
the vegetables,
and the water.
This was as late as early 1978.
So they faced this problem,
how do we persuade the public
that this dangerous technology
was worth developing,
that it made sense to continue
the funding and continue the
testing based on the argument
that we have to understand how
we might be able to survive a
nuclear attack,
but also that the Russians need
to understand that they could
not possibly initiate a nuclear
attack without committing
suicide.
So they developed a variety of
different public service
announcements,
and I'm going to show you one
of those now,
that's entitled Common
Sense.
>
Video Narrator:
Common sense tells you
this is dangerous and foolish.
You wouldn't risk your neck in
a trick like this.
Common sense tells us that
being shot out of a cannon is
dangerous business.
Common sense tells you not to
be careless at an airfield with
propellers and jet engines in
action.
And with that in mind,
this too looks dangerous,
but it's an--
>
--because they observed common
sense safety requirements.
But sometimes we forget that
security violations can be
dangerous business too.
If classified information about
this test mission fell into
enemy hands,
the consequences can be
disastrous to all of us,
individually and collectively
as a nation.
Security is only common sense.
Don't take chances,
avoid loose talk,
safeguard classified
information, report security
violations at once.
Prompt action may prevent a
minor incident from developing
into a serious one.
Avoid writing about classified
material in letters home.
Be sure you're secure!
Don't be careless!
Marilyn Monroe (on video):
I hate a careless man.
Prof: This is a U.S.
Air Force film,
and this is Marilyn Monroe,
who was, you probably know,
a film star during that period
of time.
So message there was the
technology is manageable.
Use common sense.
Avoid exposure.
And what would this mean?
What would this mean to
hundreds of millions of people
in the United States at the
time,
or to the government's
responsibility to educate them
so that they would know what to
do?
Well, Tsar Bomba and the Bravo
test basically told them that
the cities were enormously
vulnerable.
So what happened during the
Eisenhower era?
One of the first things that
was done following this was the
investment of tens of billions
of dollars in the National
Highway Program.
So the argument was,
well, we really need to be able
to move troops around the city,
but they were really concerned
about developing the capacity to
evacuate.
Is there the possibility that
we could protect against
dangerous exposures which are
most of concern,
they're highest in closest
proximity in space and time to
the site of the blast.
So if we could warn people via
sirens, via radio announcements.
If we could tell people what
they need to do in the event
that we detected an attack,
that would help them.
So not only did they build
hundreds of thousands of miles
of highways in the United States
in the hope that evacuations
might work,
but they also developed
evacuation drills.
And I don't have a shot of
Duck and Cover,
but ask your parents about
Duck and Cover.
They probably remember being
told that an emergency drill was
going to be held in the school,
all the children are now
required to get down on their
hands and knees and duck
underneath their desks and cover
their head.
In fact, there's a cute little
song that I almost developed the
courage to sing to you called
"Duck and Cover,"
but I'm going to resist doing
that.
The idea that ducking and
covering beneath your school
desk would offer you a
sufficient protection against
exposure and the damage of
collapsing buildings is quite
ridiculous.
But it was part of their
approach,
it was part of their persuasive
strategy to convince the public
that they could take
precautions,
they could get themselves into
the subway,
they could build the fallout
shelters and store it with food
and water and offer themselves
protection until the bulk of the
radiation had blown away.
Well, you know,
we've quite a bit of experience
with evacuation drills,
and a couple that you may
recall would include Hurricane
Katrina.
Hurricane Katrina found people
sitting on the highway stalled,
trying to leave southern
Louisiana and parts of Texas,
and also other parts of the
Gulf Coast.
So that moving people out of a
city, even despite having an
interstate highway system is
much more difficult than anyone
could possibly imagine.
And these are a bit out of
order, but I wanted to come back
and show you this notice.
Back in 2005,
the Connecticut State Police
ordered an evacuation of the
state.
There was no stated purpose,
but this aired on the radio and
it was out on the internet that
an evacuation of the cities was
called for.
And it was an error,
it was an electronic signal
that had been tripped.
And what was the public's
response to the evacuation
request and the warning?
Nothing.
They didn't even receive one
phone call.
So that the public is quite
actually resistant to rings of
the alarm.
So although the Bikinians were
promised that only one or two
tests would be conducted on
their island back in 1945,
more nuclear energy was
released on this one site than
at any other site in history.
So that the cumulative force of
bombs that exploded there was
nearly four times the energy
released over almost 1,000 tests
conducted at the Nevada Test
Site.
So this was labeled the most
contaminated site in the world.
And at the same time,
President Johnson was feeling
great pressure to clean up the
island and to basically remove
the radioactive sands and soils,
to restore the vegetation,
to try to figure out whether or
not fisheries might be viable so
that the population could return
to the island.
So one decade after the bombing
ceased, President Johnson gave
the okay for the Bikinians to
return to their homeland.
Now, during the next decade,
scientists continued to work,
particularly at the Brookhaven
National Laboratory on Long
Island,
and reported back to the House
and Senate.
And here's an example that the
House Appropriations Committee
heard reports from these
scientists in 1973 that the
cesium-137 concentrations were
ten times higher than the 1970
levels.
Cesium is measured in their
urine.
It's an easy radionuclide to
detect.
And it was attributed to the
foods that were grown on the
island.
So during the period when they
were restoring the soils and
they were trying to figure out
which crops they could grow,
they were often importing food.
But as they grew more and more
food on the island,
they found that the plants that
they had chosen were drawing the
radionuclides from the soils and
from the underground waters.
So they decided,
oh, well perhaps our
surveillance was not sufficient
enough.
Our sampling strategy didn't
pick up the fact that the
underlying aquifers were
contaminated or that the soil
concentrations were higher than
were originally estimated.
And they found that they had
scraped the topsoil off but they
had not gone deeply enough,
and that some of the plants
were drawing water up from a
distance that included sands and
organic matter that had absorbed
significant concentrations.
So that by 1978,
the body burden exceeded the
maximum permissible level
according to the National
Institute of Health.
They took the islanders off the
island again and they were
returned to the island of Kili,
the one that has no coral reef
surrounding,
that was open to pounding surf.
So they were allowed to stay
there for a year.
There were conflicting
interpretations of the evidence
that was available.
And we'll find this again and
again through the twentieth
century with respect to air
quality,
arguments over how much
inhalation of an air pollutant
is okay,
or how much of a drinking water
contaminant is okay,
or how much of a pesticide
residue in food is okay.
You find that often,
the government or the purveyor
of the dangerous technology will
make an argument,
"Well, you know what?
Let's average the risk."
So the Nuclear Regulatory
Commission reduced its radiation
dose estimate of the inhabitants
by averaging the exposure to the
population.
So Rosalie Bertell,
from the Nuclear Regulatory
Commission,
protested to this,
arguing, "This is like
telling one smoking member of a
family his or her risk of lung
cancer is lowered if the other
non-smoking members of the
family are included and an
average risk is given.
It's scientifically ridiculous
as an approach to public
health."
So this idea of averaging risk
across people when you have some
people that would be more
exposed than others,
some people would have a diet
that might be high in coconut
milk.
And during periods of drought
throughout the Marshall Islands
in the Pacific,
it's pretty well known that the
islanders stayed hydrated by
drinking more and more coconut
milk.
Coconut milk happens to be
loaded with saturated fats.
So the saturated fats were very
effective in binding on to some
of the radionuclides.
And that explained why the
drought was correlated with an
increase in the body
concentration of some of the
compounds.
So the idea of averaging that
across the entire population,
across space and time,
made no sense.
By 1999, the Government
Accounting Office,
is what it used to be called.
By the way, that's now the
Government Accountability
Office, if you ever are
searching for it.
And it's a great site to look
at for critical evaluations of
government activities,
and particularly with respect
to environmental and health
problems associated with
dangerous technologies,
that's Government
Accountability Office.
They argued for restricted
access and that if the return of
the former residents occurred,
that it would expose them to
dangerous levels of radiation
despite the fact that they spent
$100 million trying to restore
the site.
By 1980, the Department of
Energy concluded that the
Bikinians could return to Enyu
Island,
which is one location in the
Bikini Atoll that received the
least amount of radiation,
but only if they ate no more
than fifty percent of locally
grown food and spent no more
than ten percent of their time
on Bikini Island.
So this idea that they could
adjust their behavior in a way
that would reduce their exposure
is a very interesting one.
One of the islanders,
Pero Joel in 1989,
reflected on the second exodus
from the island,
saying:
"Finally,
the Americans and the
scientists came back a few years
later saying that we had to
leave again.
They said we had ingested too
much poison and that it wasn't
safe to live on Bikini anymore.
And we didn't care at this
point, because we had already
started to get that hopeless
feeling again though because we
all wanted to stay on Bikini,
we did explore all
possibilities in an attempt to
find a way out of this problem.
We kept thinking the Americans
first told us it was safe to
live here.
Then they changed their minds
and some rules for us to follow.
Now they're telling us to leave.
And should we go?"
So they were constantly being
manipulated by estimates of what
was risky and what was safe.
And gradually,
this became the site of
extended epidemiological studies
of the health very carefully
correlated with measurements of
nuclides in their body.
The quality of the science is
really extraordinary.
Again, it's exemplary in the
twentieth century.
And they found that thyroid
disease on the islands that
experienced the greatest fallout
was excessive.
More than a third of all the
residents have thyroid disease
on Rongelap.
Rongelap was an island that,
following the Bravo test,
that thermonuclear explosion,
the hydrogen bomb,
they hadn't expected that the
ash would reach Rongelap.
But the ash fell out of the sky
like it was snow,
and the children were described
as running along the beach
picking up the snow and throwing
it over their heads,
eating it and rubbing it into
their skin.
And it didn't take long before
they realized that something was
terribly awry,
and their skin started to burn.
They became nauseous and
vomited because of their
radiation poisoning.
Then they lost their hair.
So that the combination of
exposure to strontium that
lodges in the bone to the
iodine-131 that lodges in the
thyroid eventually led to this
thyroid disease.
So what are the remedies?
What are the remedies for a
population such as this?
Well, we'll come back to this
when we get back together on
Thursday, but litigation is one.
Litigation is a really
difficult approach,
because of the amount of time
it normally takes,
but also the amount of funding
that it would take.
And litigation that would be
brought against the United
States government would be
fought intensively.
So that it's not uncommon for
litigation to span a period of
time including a decade.
Financial compensation.
Financial compensation to those
that can demonstrate that they
had their property taken away,
that they had their livelihoods
taken away,
or that they lost their health.
Financial support,
so the building of schools or
hospitals or roadways or job
training,
that's another possible form of
support or community
development.
Medical monitoring and medical
treatment,
and also the landscape
restoration costs,
such as those that occurred
when they removed the soils,
when they brought in the trees
that cost the government $100
million.
So I'll close with a slide that
a $20 million resettlement trust
fund for the people of Bikini
was authorized by Congress.
And it was later supplemented
with an additional $90 million.
And these were used for the
construction and resettlement of
the Bikinians to live on Kili
Island in another atoll nearby.
And a fiscal year budget now
ranges between about 7 million
and $10 million that's going
into this community that
originally was only several
hundred people in size.
So we'll come back to this
again on Thursday.
And once again,
my apologies for being late
today.